hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
July the third today and you assumed in
two games what news first up Gears of
War dev and industry veteran clips
wszyscy how surprised absolutely nobody
by coming out of retirement and getting
set to announce his next project
bleszinski left epic games in late 2012
after spending twenty years with the
company he may have been off the map but
he's still been kicking around various
industry events and making the odd
outspoken tweet for everybody to morph
into gaming news speaking of Twitter
that's exactly where he announced that
he was coming out of retirement and now
he's posted a link to a countdown clock
on there and it's a good guess that when
the clock wraps up at nine a.m. PT on
july eight we'll be hearing about his
new project he said it's going to be a
blast to finally tell the story of what
brought me back next up is some sad news
as the developer of murdered soul
suspect airtight games has gone under
the developer have tweeted out a thank
you to those who contributed to their
games and their fans family friends and
colleagues the closure has come less
than a month after the release of
murdered soul suspect and was reported
by geekwire the site snapped a photo of
a sign saying that office equipment was
being sold off with heavy discounts and
that the studio was indeed shutting down
airtight games opened in 2004 and with
best known as the former workplace of
Kim Swift who created the original
portal and help them make games like
quantum conundrum and the Ouya exclusive
soul fjord we wish all the very best to
everybody affected by the studio closure
next up holy esports drama was all
pretty much anybody could talk about
yesterday so let's get you all covered
off on exactly what happened the finnish
qualifies for an upcoming international
eSports federation tournament was
barring women from participating in
hearthstone matches weirdly not only
with their gender divisions but the
games being made available to men and
women were very different men were
flooded in for dota 2 starcraft 2 heart
stone and ultra street fighter 4 while
women were offered tekken tag tournament
instead of hearthstone and street
fighter in their defense the finnish
organizes a group called assembly said
they had
to make that qualify as male only
because the South Korean bass tournament
itself is male only which is fair they
also said they want to be seen as a
legitimate sport and so dividing male
and female competitions was done in
accordance with international sports
authority as part of their efforts to
promote eSports as legitimate sports
which makes less sense as you can
imagine this did not sit well with an
awful lot of people and the I ESF
appeared to take a backseat for a bit
and figure out how to claw their way out
of the media hate cyclone but now
they've come to say that it is important
for them to have a female division to
encourage more women to get into eSports
where they're quite underrepresented in
addition they've completely reversed
their former decisions and now the
hearth stone tournament is open to all
players the IE SF now have two event
categories and open for all category for
men and women in addition to events that
are reserved just for women I think I
can say that that one is wrapped up
pretty nicely let me know down in that
comment e section if you think the
gender division in eSports makes sense
or if you think it's crazy those are all
the things that I wanted to tell you
about today but be sure to join the same
time tomorrow for some top 5 goodness
I'll catch event